The social and behavioral sciences have much to say about the reasons for many of our behaviors in response to the novel coronavirus. How we perceive and navigate threats, whether we believe conspiracy theories, how we demonstrate altruism or not, are all behaviors that scientists for many disciplines have studied for years. In late March, several scholars posted a preprint of an article that was developed by pulling together experts from many disciplines to look at what the research tells us about these and other behaviors. What they concluded may help at least some of us better understand why we're doing what we're doing, and if we're attentive and intentional, these insights might actually help us
社会与 behavioral 科学对于我们在应对新型冠状病毒时的许多行为原因有很多看法。我们如何感知和应对威胁、我们是否相信阴谋论、我们如何表现出利他主义与否，都是多年来来自多个学科的科学家一直在研究的行为。三月下旬，几位学者发布了一篇预印本文章，该文章是通过汇集许多学科的专家来研究研究告诉我们关于这些和其他行为的内容而撰写得出的。他们得出的结论可能至少能帮助我们中的一些人更好地理解我们为什么要做我们正在做的事情，如果我们保持专注并有意图，这些见解实际上可能会帮助我们
act in ways that will help flatten the COVID-19 curve. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. J. Van Bavel, an expert on group identities, moral values, and political beliefs. He is an associate professor of psychology and neural science at New York University, where he directs the social perception and evaluation lab. His research examines implicit bias, diversity and inclusion, team performance, cooperation, and decision making. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Van Bable. Hi, it's nice to be here. Great. You recently gathered something like 41 experts to draft a summary of
以有助于拉平COVID-19曲线的方式行动。欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是J.范巴韦尔（J. Van Bavel）博士，他是群体认同、道德价值观和政治信仰方面的专家。他是纽约大学心理学和神经科学副教授，并在那里领导社会感知与评估实验室。他的研究涉及内隐偏见、多元化与包容性、团队绩效、合作以及决策制定。欢迎来到《心理学说话》，范巴韦尔博士。嗨，很高兴来到这里。太好了。你最近召集了大约41位专家来起草一份总结报告，
research findings relevant to how best to handle the COVID-19 response. And you published this article that United Psychologists, Economists, Sociologists, and others for a review of research on fake news and conspiracy theories, leadership, threat perception, and other issues that are all at play in the ongoing public health crisis. Can you tell our listeners some of what you all concluded? Yeah. So basically, what we tried to do is pull together what we thought was the best evidence and research in many fields that might be relevant to COVID-19. So obviously, COVID-19 is new, and we're doing tons of research on it right now, but there isn't a lot of published research.
其中包含与如何最好地处理COVID-19应对措施相关的研究发现。你发表了这篇文章，该文章联合了心理学家、经济学家、社会学家和其他人员，对有关假新闻和阴谋论、领导力、威胁感知以及在正在发生的公共卫生危机中发挥作用的其他问题的研究进行了审查。你能否向我们的听众介绍你们得出的一些结论？好的。所以基本上，我们试图做的是汇集我们认为在许多领域中可能与COVID-19相关的最佳证据和研究。显然，COVID-19是全新的，我们现在正在对其进行大量研究，但并没有很多已发表的研究。
So we drew as much as we could from prior pandemics, public health messages, and other topics that we thought were relevant. And many of the ideas that we came up were around things like, you know, getting people to manage the threats, encouraging social connection during a period of isolation and distancing, also work on how to deal with misinformation. So you mentioned conspiracy theories as well as fake news and how to give leaders and members of the public insights about what ways they can engage in effective persuasion and communication. And so we tried to pull all that together.
因此，我们尽可能地从以往的大流行病、公共卫生信息以及我们认为相关的其他主题中汲取灵感。我们提出的许多想法都围绕着诸如，引导人们管理威胁、在孤立和隔离期间鼓励社会联系、以及如何处理错误信息的研究。所以你提到了阴谋论以及假新闻，以及如何向领导者和公众提供关于他们可以采用哪些方式进行有效说服和沟通的见解。因此，我们试图将所有这些结合起来。
And again, our paper is really a consensus across sciences. It's not just psychological science, but collaboration between many. people in many different disciplines to figure out what we kind of tended to agree on across all of these different disciplines. One concept that your paper discusses is optimism bias, the notion that bad things are more likely to happen to other people, not to me. How can leaders use communication strategies that strike a balance between breaking through this optimism bias without inducing excessive feelings of anxiety and dread? Yeah, dealing with optimism bias is challenging. And optimism bias in this context
而且再次强调，我们的论文确实是各科学领域的共识。它不仅是心理科学，而且是许多不同学科的许多人之间的合作，以弄清楚我们在所有这些不同的学科中倾向于达成一致的意见。你的论文讨论的一个概念是乐观偏差，即坏事更有可能发生在其他人身上而不是我身上的观念。领导者如何使用沟通策略，在打破这种乐观偏差与不引起过度的焦虑和恐惧感之间取得平衡？是的，应对乐观偏差具有挑战性。而这种背景下的乐观偏差
essentially takes a form of understanding the risks. Maybe you're watching the news or TV and you realize there's a very real risk of this virus spreading and people maybe even in your community getting the disease. But you might think optimistically that you're not going to get it. And if you have that thought
本质上采取了理解风险的形式。也许你正在看新闻或电视，并且意识到这种病毒传播以及人们甚至可能在你的社区中感染该疾病的风险非常真实。但你可能会乐观地认为你不会感染它。如果你有这种想法
that you are less likely to get it than the next person, then you might be more inclined to take risks. And that might mean going out more, traveling more, maybe being less inclined to do things like where, a mask. And naturally, if you do those things, that puts you at risk. And so one of the things that we're trying to communicate to people is that even if they're effective at communicating the risks, they nevertheless have to change the behavior of specific individuals. And one way,
即你比旁人更不可能感染，那么你可能更倾向于冒险。这可能意味着更多地外出、更多地旅行，甚至可能更不愿意做诸如戴口罩之类的事情。自然地，如果你做了这些事情，就会让自己处于危险之中。因此，我们试图向人们传达的事情之一是，即使他们在传达风险方面很有效，他们仍然必须改变特定个体的行为。而其中一种方法，
one section we have is on social norms. And it turns out that social norms in many different areas tend to be an effective way of changing behaviors, even if people don't necessarily change their own attitudes or perceptions. So if they see other people where, wearing masks and you can kind of find good role models and ways of communicating that as the new norm, then people might do it even if they don't necessarily think that they're at a particular high risk. They'll do it because it's normative because when they walk in a restaurant, everybody else is wearing masks or because when they walk down a running trail, everybody else is wearing masks. And so that's essentially what we try to do is basically provide insights from the
我们有一个关于社会规范的章节。事实证明，许多不同领域的社会规范往往是改变行为的有效方法，即使人们不一定改变他们自己的态度或看法。因此，如果他们看到其他人戴口罩，并且你可以找到好的榜样以及将这一点作为新规范进行沟通的方法，那么人们可能会这样做，即使他们不一定认为自己处于特别高的风险中。他们会这样做是因为这是规范性的，因为当他们走进餐馆时，其他所有人都在戴口罩，或者因为当他们走在跑步小径上时，其他所有人都在戴口罩。所以这基本上就是我们试图做的事情，即提供来自文献中的见解，
literature that might be effective ways to move the needle on some of these public health behaviors, especially despite the types of psychological shortcuts and heuristics people often make. I have one family member who says it's okay to go out where she lives, which is on an island in Florida, because no one on that island has died from COVID yet. But she's over 80 and has lung ailments, and thus she's part of the highest risk cohort. How do we get through to people like that who, it seems, just don't grasp the mathematical probability of getting ill? Yeah, so one thing we might need to do is, find ways of communicating the norm to her.
这些文献可能是推动其中一些公共卫生行为发生改变的有效途径，特别是尽管人们经常采取心理捷径和启发式方法。我有一个家庭成员说，在她居住的弗罗里达州的一个岛上出门是没问题的，因为该岛上还没有人死于COVID。但她已经80多岁了，患有肺部疾病，因此她是最高风险人群的一部分。我们如何才能说服这样的人，他们似乎就是不明白生病的数学概率？是的，所以我们可能需要做的一件事是，找到向她传达规范的方法。
So if the people in your friend's community are wearing masks, or if your friend is a member of a local church or parish or synagogue or mosque, if the religious leaders in that community wear masks and model it, that might be something that nudges your friend to do it. Even if they don't think that they're at unique risk, they might think they're still relatively safe, but if everybody else is doing it and they're going to get eyes rolled at them or people making comments to them when they're out,
因此，如果你的朋友社区中的人们正在戴口罩，或者如果你的朋友是当地教堂、教区、犹太教堂或清真寺的成员，如果该社区的宗教领袖戴口罩并树立榜样，这可能会成为促使你的朋友也这样做的微小推动力。即使他们不认为自己面临独特的风险，他们可能仍然认为自己相对安全，但如果其他所有人在这样做，并且当他们外出时，人们会对他们翻白眼或对他们评头论足，
they might be more like to wear a mask, even if they don't think it's particularly risky in their island or neighborhood or what have you. Yeah, but we're talking about Florida. You know what's happening down there. I feel like every news story starts with, you know, Florida man or Florida woman and some remarkable story. But I'm in New York, so I don't think I can talk about, you know, with too much confidence. We've obviously struggled with our own rates. And I think one of the things that's challenging with this particular virus is people don't have good, models of predicting risk, especially for exponential, you know, spread, because the way it works is that there's only a couple people who might have it in your community. And then a week later, it's grown
他们可能更有可能戴上口罩，即使他们不认为在他们的岛屿或街区或诸如此类的地方特别危险。是的，但我们在谈论弗罗里达州。你知道那里正在发生什么。我觉得每一篇新闻报道都是以“弗罗里达男子”或“弗罗里达女子”以及一些奇特的的故事开始的。但我在纽约，所以我认为我不能带有太多信心地谈论这一点。我们显然一直在努力应对我们自己的比率。我认为这种特殊病毒带来的挑战之一是人们没有很好的模型来预测风险，特别是对于指数级传播，因为它的运作方式是你的社区中可能只有几个人携带它。然后一周后，它呈指数级增长
exponentially and it's a huge amount, which is essentially what happened in New York. I remember colleagues and friends saying, well, New York's not at that big of risk. You know, they could see the data in Italy. They could see some infections around New York. But there weren't that many deaths in New York at the time. And then a week later, it had blown up. And by then it was out of control. and we've now got it mostly under control, but it's, you know, we're the world's hot spot, and it was a week before it blew up that I had really smart people around me saying it's not going to be that big of an issue in New York. So that's unfortunately one of the psychological challenges of dealing with infectious diseases like this. A lot of people tend to expect that there'll be a real panic during a disaster like this.
并且数量巨大，这基本上就是纽约发生的事情。我记得同事和朋友说，纽约的风险没那么大。你知道，他们可以看到意大利的数据。他们可以看到纽约周围的一些感染情况。但当时纽约并没有那么多死亡病例。然后一周后，它爆发了。到了那时，它已经失控了。我们现在基本上把它控制住了，但是，你知道的，我们是世界的热点地区，就在它爆发的前一周，我身边非常聪明的人还在对我说，这在纽约不会成为什么大问题。所以不幸的是，这是应对此类传染病的心理挑战之一。许多人在像这样的大灾难期间往往会期望出现真正的恐慌。
And it doesn't seem to be happening other than this talk about panic buying, which might not even be a real thing. What does the research say about panic during disasters? Yeah, that's a great question. And to be honest, that was one of the most surprising literatures that we included in our paper. So there's research by John Drury and Steve Reacher and others who has explored large groups and when they engage in things like panic versus not. And they find that the notion of panic is actually vastly overblown. So if you watch Hollywood movies about outbreaks and pandemics, they often show images of riding
然而除了这种关于抢购的讨论（这甚至可能不是真实的）之外，这种情况似乎并没有发生。关于灾难期间的恐慌，研究是怎么说的？是的，这是一个很好的问题。老实说，这是我们论文中包含的最令人惊讶的文献之一。约翰·德鲁伊（John Drury）和史蒂夫·里奇（Steve Reacher）等人进行了研究，他们探讨了大型群体以及他们何时会陷入恐慌与否。他们发现，恐慌的概念实际上被极大地夸大了。因此，如果你看好莱坞关于疫情和大流行的电影，它们经常会展示暴乱的画面
and panic. That's kind of the images that the media in the United States started to show during the early stages of the coronavirus when they showed, you know, images of empty shelves and people, you know, there might be two women fighting over the last rolls of toilet paper at a supermarket. And surely there were some things that were scarce for a period of time. But the whole notion of panic, again, I'll just say, I'm in, I live in Manhattan, and you haven't seen almost any of that. In fact, you haven't seen almost almost any of it anywhere in the United States around the world. It's been very rare.
和恐慌。这正是美国媒体在冠状病毒早期阶段开始展示的画面，当时他们展示了诸如空货架的照片以及人们可能在超市里为最后几卷卫生纸而争斗的场景。当然，在一段时间内确实有些物资是稀缺的。但关于恐慌的整个概念，我只想说，我住在曼哈顿，你几乎看不到任何那种情况。事实上，你在美国甚至世界各地的任何地方都几乎看不到任何那种情况。那非常罕见。
And so their research really suggests that when you get keep people dealing in these situations, they often come together and have a remarkable amount of collective resilience. And the notion of panic is, you know, mostly wrong scientifically and certainly vastly oversold. So that's one of the things where there's kind of a counterintuitive finding from the science that kind of goes against our intuitions and certainly what we expect from watching movies about similar situations. What have you observed about how social networks are spreading helpful and harmful information?
因此，他们的研究确实表明，当你让人们在这些情况下保持冷静时，他们经常会团结在一起，并表现出惊人的集体韧性。而恐慌的概念，你知道的，在科学上大多是错误的，而且肯定被大大言过其实了。所以这正是科学中的一种反直觉发现，它在某种程度上违背了我们的直觉，也肯定违背了我们从观看类似情况的电影中所期望的内容。你对社交网络如何传播有用和有害的信息观察到了什么？
And are they tending more one way than the other? Yeah, so I do research myself on social networks and how information spreads online. And obviously, this is a big issue in a pandemic, right? Because this is where epidemiologists study the structure of social networks and how viruses spread. But there's been a lot of research in the last decade or so looking at how information spreads. and using basically those classic epidemiological models to understand things like how messages go viral. Now, a lot of that work, especially in the last few years, has started to look at things like fake news, misinformation, conspiracy theories. And my lab studies those topics as well.
它们是更倾向于某一方还是另一方？是的，所以我自己也对社交网络以及信息如何在网上传播进行了研究。显然，在大流行病中这是一个大问题，对吧？因为流行病学家就是在这里研究社交网络的结构以及病毒如何传播的。但在过去十年左右的时间里，有大量研究探讨了信息的传播。并基本上使用那些经典的流行病学模型来理解诸如信息如何病毒式传播之类的事情。现在，其中许多工作，特别是在过去几年里，已经开始关注假新闻、错误信息、阴谋论等事情。我的实验室也在研究这些主题。
What we find is that, first of all, most people are not conspiracy theorists. So when I'm going to talk about things like conspiracy theories, just understand these people are in the minority. But what you should also understand is that when these messages that they have do go viral, millions of people can watch them now because of social media. So there was a recent video that went viral, I believe it was called the Plandemic. Yeah. And it was this conspiracy theory video on YouTube and it was watched millions and millions of times within a few days. And it was, again, just a very twisted conspiracy theory without much evidence behind it. And it only takes a couple people spreading those for it to get to millions of eyes in a way that just would have been impossible, you know, 20 or 30 years ago for a conspiracy theorist to spread information.
我们发现，首先，大多数人不是阴谋论者。因此，当我谈论诸如阴谋论之类的事情时，请理解这些人是少数。但你也应该理解的是，当他们拥有的这些消息确实病毒式传播时，由于社交媒体，现在数百万人可以观看它们。所以最近有一个病毒式传播的视频，我相信它叫《Plandemic》（阴谋计划）。是的。这是YouTube上的一个阴谋论视频，在几天内被数百万甚至数千万人观看。而且，它再次只是一个非常扭曲的阴谋论，后面没有多少证据支持。只需几个人传播这些信息，就能让数百万双眼睛看到它，而在20或30年前，阴谋论者要想以这种方式传播信息是绝对不可能的。
And so social media allows people to leverage social networks and weaponize misinformation. There was an article in the New York Times a couple weeks ago about a conspiracy theory that coronavirus was being spread by 5G wireless towers. and there were over a hundred attacks on towers or people who worked for the telecommunications companies. And so those are real behaviors. They're putting people at danger. And not only are they putting those employees and structures at risk,
因此，社交媒体允许人们利用社交网络并将错误信息武器化。《纽约时报》几周前有一篇文章，关于一个阴谋论，称冠状病毒是由5G无线发射塔传播的。并且发生了针对发射塔或电信公司员工的一百多次袭击。所以这些是真实的行为。它们正使人们处于危险之中。不仅这些员工和基础设施面临风险，
but if they knock down a 5G tower, there goes a lot of people's access to social connection through, you know, like Zoom meetings and Skyping their friends and family. A lot of kids like my kids right now are homeschooling. their internet and Wi-Fi is their capacity to learn. And so it's doing that. And then the third thing I think that is the risk with conspiracy theories is
而且如果他们撞倒了一5G发射塔，许多人通过诸如Zoom会议和与朋友和家人Skype等方式建立社会联系的通道就会消失。许多像我现在的孩子一样的孩子在家上学。他们的互联网和Wi-Fi是他们的学习能力。所以它正在造成这种影响。然后我认为阴谋论带来的第三个风险是
if those people are getting out and they're not taking the medical messaging seriously, they're putting themselves at risk. And in a pandemic, that means they're putting everybody at risk in catching the disease. So this is the reason that we're worried about things like conspiracy theories and misinformation. It's not just because, you know, those people are, it seems crazy to us. But there's a risk that they spread things throughout the entire community if they're not taking the actual medical information seriously. What makes our brains so susceptible to these wacky theories? That's a good question.
如果这些人外出并且不认真对待医疗信息，他们就会让自己处于危险之中。在大流行病中，这意味着他们在感染疾病时将每个人都置于危险之中。这就是为什么我们担心诸如阴谋论和错误信息之理由。这不仅仅是因为，你知道的，那些人，在我们看来很疯狂。而是存在一种风险，即如果他们不认真对待实际的医疗信息，他们就会将事情传播到整个社区。是什么让我们的大脑如此容易受到这些古怪理论的影响？这是一个好问题。
So there's lots of different elements of it. So there's certain types of personality styles that are more or less susceptible to misinformation. We have a paper in my lab we just submitted yesterday that finds people who kind of have overinflated views of their nation and their national identity. They think their country is unique and special are very likely, it turns out, to believe and share conspiracy theories about COVID-19. One of the reasons we think is because the pandemic is threatening to their country. If it spreads, it proves that their country isn't that great or unique, as they might think. And we found this in the United States, but we've also found it in Britain. So that's one personality style we found that turns out to be a really powerful predictor of conspiracy theory belief.
所以这有很多不同的元素。因此，存在某些类型的人格风格，它们对错误信息的易感性或高或低。我的实验室昨天刚提交了一篇论文，发现那些对其国家和国家认同持有过度膨胀观点的人——他们认为自己的国家是独特而特殊的——结果极有可能相信并分享关于COVID-19的阴谋论。我们认为原因之一是大流行病对他们的国家构成了威胁。如果它蔓延开来，就证明他们的国家并不像他们想象的那样伟大或独特。我们在美国发现了这一点，但在英国也发现了这一点。所以这是我们发现的一种人格风格，它被证明是阴谋论信念的一个非常强大的预测指标。
But there's lots of other work around, you know, when people have needs for control or understanding and during a pandemic, you know, they've kind of lost control and they don't fully understand it. So that can heighten conspiracy theories. You also see many conspiracy theories are xenophobic. They're often about another nation has created the disease. So there's obviously a conspiracy theory that it was created. and weaponized by the Chinese government. But if you look in other countries, there's conspiracy theories
但还有许多其他关于以下方面的研究：当人们对控制或理解有需求时，在大流行病期间，你知道的，他们已经失去了控制并且没有完全理解它。因此，这会加剧阴谋论。你还会发现许多阴谋论是排外的。它们通常关于另一个国家创造了这种疾病。因此，显然存在一种阴谋论，认为它是被中国政府创造并武器化的。但如果你看看其他国家，就会发现有阴谋论
that the United States is behind it. And so it's a way of a conspiracy theory is often interwoven with group identities and kind of negative, malicious beliefs about certain groups as well. There's research into this concept of nudges, little things that move people in certain directions. I'm wondering, can you list some examples
认为美国是幕后黑手。因此，阴谋论通常与群体认同以及对某些群体的负面、恶意的信念交织在一起。有研究探讨了“助推”（nudges）这一概念，即推动人们朝特定方向发展的小事情。我想知道，你能列举一些例子吗？
of nudges you've seen that are influencing people's behaviors and explain how they work? Yeah, so nudges are basically a soft way of managing behavior. So you have the hard, forceful way of managing behavior, which has been happening in many countries, which is like a lockdown. You saw that in Wuhan and China first, where they have an authoritarian government that can just completely lock everybody at home. But you're seeing it in American states where governors are demanding that all
你所看到的正在影响人们行为的助推，并解释它们是如何运作的？是的，所以助推基本上是管理行为的一种温和方式。所以你有管理行为的强硬、强力方式，这在许多国家一直在发生，比如封锁。你首先在中国的武汉看到了这一点，那里有一个威权政府，可以完全把每个人关在家里。但你也可以在美国各州看到这一点，那里的州长要求所有
restaurants stay closed and closing all the schools. And so sometimes you need that, you know, to save lives. But it's hard to sustain. So people might get exhausted or tired or frustrated. And so you need other ways of encouraging them to engage in the right behaviors to promote public health for a long period of time. I mean, in New York, it's been, I believe, two months or more since, you know, I was told that my university was closing and my kids' schools were closing. So what can you do to encourage people like me to continue doing the things that promote my safety and the safety? of people in my community.
餐厅保持关闭，所有学校也都在关闭。有时候你确实需要这些举措来挽救生命。但这是很难维持的。人们可能会感到筋疲力尽、厌烦或沮丧。因此，你需要其他方法来鼓励他们在很长一段时间内采取正确的行为来促进公共卫生。我的意思是，在纽约，自我听说我的大学和孩子们的学校关闭以来，已经过去大约两个月甚至更久了。那么，你能做些什么来鼓励像我这样的人继续做那些能促进我安全以及社区中其他人安全的事情呢？
And so nudges are ways of framing issues and decisions that lead to the right behavior. And this is also one of the places where social norms come in. So I was just watching our Governor Andrew Cuomo's press briefing about an hour ago. And his daughter solicited little mini ads to encourage people to wear masks because he's realizing that's going to be really key to promoting safety in New York and reopening things. And so one of the things In a couple of the ads that were really clever One of the things they did was they had a wide variety
因此，助推（nudges）是一种构建问题和决策的方式，能够引导人们做出正确的行为。这也是社会规范发挥作用的地方之一。我大约一个小时前刚看了我们的州长安德鲁·库默的新闻发布会。他的女儿征集了一些微型广告来鼓励人们佩戴口罩，因为他意识到这对于提升纽约的安全和重启经济至关重要。因此，在其中几个非常聪明的广告中，他们做的一件事是让各种各样
of different New Yorkers putting on the masks for different reasons. So people from all different ethnicities, ages. And so in those ads, there's a good chance that there's someone that looks like you that's wearing the mask. And so I thought that was really good. They also had another ad with a guy
不同背景的纽约人为了各种原因戴上口罩。有来自各个不同种族、年龄的人。所以在这些广告中，很有可能会有一个长得和你很像的人也戴着口罩。所以我觉得这非常好。他们还制作了另一个广告，里面有一个人
in front of a building or a subway and he had a shirt that said, that guy on it. And he wasn't wearing a mask and everyone around it around him was. And it's, yeah, look at that guy. Yeah. He's that guy, the guy who feels like he doesn't have to wear a mask in the subway. And I saw it and I like you, I just instantly laughed. And we all kind of have this notion that we're out in public and there is a guy like that just feels like they can put everybody else at risk. And so it was modeling not only the right behavior, but differentiating it from the wrong behavior and signaling that's wrong, wearing the mask is right. And you're going to kind of look like that.
站在一栋建筑或地铁站前，他穿的衬衫上写着“那家伙”三个字。他没有戴口罩，而他周围的所有人都戴了。然后人们就会说，“看那个家伙。没错，他就是那个家伙，那个觉得自己不用在地铁里戴口罩的人。”我看到了，和你一样，我立刻笑了起来。我们大家都有这种概念，当我们身处公共场所时，总会有这样一个家伙，觉得自己可以置所有人于危险之中。因此，这不仅是在塑造正确行为，还将它与错误行为区分开来，并发出信号：错误的是不戴口罩，正确的是戴口罩。而且你看起来会有点像
guy and that's how people are going to think of you, even if they're not saying it when you're out without a mask. And so it was like subtle. It didn't require any like shaming or harassment of the person. It just clearly signaled don't be that guy. And so there was lots of like really clever. Those were the finalists for this video messaging competition. And I thought they were, you know, they were funny. They resonated with people that seemed real, but also a lot of the models were people who looked like all kinds of New Yorkers. And so I think that is one of the, you know, things I thought it was really clever and well done. And so I think like there's lots of subtle ways.
那个家伙，别人也会这样看你，即使他们在你没戴口罩出门时并没有当面说出来。所以这很微妙。它不需要对这个人进行任何羞辱或骚扰。它只是清晰地传达了信号：别做那种人。所以有很多非常聪明的做法。这些是视频信息征集比赛的决赛作品。我认为它们既有趣，又与人们产生共鸣，显得很真实，而且许多模特都是各种各样的纽约人。所以我认为这是我觉得非常聪明且做得很好的地方之一。因此我认为有很多微妙的方法。
Another thing that's happening in New York is police are going around because it's getting warm out and they will go to the parks and hand out masks. And so instead of arresting people or coercing people, they're making it as easy for them as possible to wear a mask by giving them free ones. And then the next thing that happens, if those people put on the mask, the police leave, new people come to the park and see that everybody's wearing a mask. And that means they'll be more likely to wear a mask just to fit in. And so it's a really clever, it kind of does two things.
纽约发生的另一件事是警察四处走动，因为天气变暖了，他们会去公园分发口罩。因此，他们没有逮捕或强迫人们，而是通过免费赠送口罩，让人们尽可能容易地佩戴口罩。接下来发生的事情是，如果这些人戴上了口罩，警察就会离开，新的人来到公园，看到每个人都戴着口罩。这意味着他们也会更有可能为了融入群体而戴上口罩。所以这是一个非常聪明的做法，它起到了两个作用。
By making it easy and natural for people to wear a mask and the police handing them out to make them free, it's more likely to lead them to do it, and they don't feel coerced and reactive. And at the same time, they're there now sitting in the park with masks on. The next wave of people comes and sees, and they get a signal that that's the normative thing to do. And so I thought that was a really clever, subtle way to nudge the right behavior. And if you do that over a long enough period, and now people start wearing masks, it becomes a habit. an norm and it's easier to kind of continue that as a way of doing things in the city. And it's so smart because cops are authority figures and here they are instead of doing
通过让人们轻松自然地戴上口罩，并且由警察免费分发，这更有可能促使人们照做，而不会让他们感到被强迫并产生抗拒心理。与此同时，他们现在戴着口罩坐在公园里。下一波人来到这里看到了，就会收到一个信号，知道这是规范的做法。所以我认为这是一种非常巧妙、微妙的方式来助推正确的行为。如果你能在足够长的时间里持续这样做，现在人们开始佩戴口罩，它就会成为一种习惯和规范，并且更容易在城市中作为一种做事方式延续下去。这太聪明了，因为警察是权威人物，而在这里，他们没有采取
something punitive, you know, they're urging you in a way that you kind of feel like, how could I say no? It was a policeman who gave me the mask. Yeah. And it's also, I had a former colleague at NYU, Tom Tyler, who did work on procedural justice. And he talked about the need for a police to work with the community and have relationships with the community so that they're seen as legitimate. And so it also helps with relationships between the community and the police. The police are seen as illegitimate
惩罚性的措施，而是用一种让你觉得“我怎么能拒绝？”的方式来敦促你。是警察把口罩给我的。是的。而且，我在纽约大学的前同事汤姆·泰勒曾做过关于程序正义的研究。他谈到了警察需要与社区合作并建立关系，以便被视为具有合法性。因此，这也有助于改善社区与警察之间的关系。如果警察被视为滥用权力、具有强制性或选择性地针对某些群体，他们就会被认为缺乏合法性
when they are seen as abusing their authority or being coercive or selectively targeting certain groups. And certainly the New York police in the past couple weeks have been accused of only ticketing or arresting minorities who weren't wearing masks. And so I'm not saying that the police are perfect, but I think a community policing model
过去几周里，纽约警方当然被指控只对未佩戴口罩的少数族裔开罚单或实施逮捕。因此，我并不是说警察是完美的，但我认为社区警务模式
where they're working with the public to help them is probably a much smarter strategy. And as long as they're doing that evenly across the city with all different groups and not, you know, only for some groups and not for others, I think is really key. But there's ways to do it that are smart, that are consistent with social science and that are, you know, they're not perfect, but they move the needle in a way that promotes everybody's health. Let's talk globally for a minute. Your pre-print article talks about tight cultures compared with the loose cultures.
即他们与公众合作以提供帮助，可能是一个更聪明的策略。只要他们在整个城市中对所有不同群体都公平地做到这一点，而不是只针对某些群体，我认为这绝对是关键所在。但是，有一些方法是聪明的，符合社会科学的，虽然它们不是完美的，但它们确实以一种促进每个人健康的方式推动了事情的发展。让我们从全球视角谈一会儿。你们的预印本文章讨论了紧密文化与宽松文化的对比。
What are those concepts mean and how are they influencing? how certain countries are reacting to the coronavirus. Yeah, so there's a whole section we have on culture, and we had some cross-cultural experts, including Chernobyl Kiryama and Chu Hi Han, who's in China. We have Michelle Gelfand, who does a lot of work on tightness or looseness of cultures, and they did a great job of putting together the section on different factors of culture that matter. So I'll just kind of zoom out for a second, and if you look around the world,
这些概念是什么意思，它们又是如何影响某些国家对冠状病毒的反应的？是的，我们有一整节专门讨论文化，我们邀请了一些跨文化专家，包括栗山茂久（Chernobyl Kiryama）和在中国的中智韩（Chu Hi Han）。还有米歇尔·格尔芬德（Michelle Gelfand），她在文化紧密性或宽松性方面做了大量研究，他们非常出色地完成了关于文化中重要不同因素的那一部分内容。所以我先退一步，从宏观上看，如果你环顾世界各地，
you can see that different nations are doing well or worse in the current pandemic in terms of managing the spread of the coronavirus. And what you can see in particular is a lot of cultures in the East are doing much better, especially in Asia. And so there's lots of potential cultural factors that might account for that. So one of the first one we noticed was the difference between individual and collectivism is there's some evidence in previous work that in collectivist cultures, People over there are not only more comfortable wearing masks and have different cultural practices around greeting people, but they're potentially more receptive to messages about the collective, about promoting the good of everybody and making individual sacrifices. And in the U.S., for example, where you can see protests against quarantining, again, it's a small number of Americans who are doing these protests, but the way it's framed and it's supported by the president here are through messages of individual freedom. So individualism. And so you can see where that in a pandemic, that becomes a problem, right?
你会发现不同的国家在当前的疫情中控制冠状病毒传播方面的表现有好有坏。你可以特别注意到，东方许多国家的表现要好得多，尤其是在亚洲。因此，有很多潜在的文化因素可以解释这一点。我们注意到的第一个因素是个人主义和集体主义之间的差异。以往研究的一些证据表明，在集体主义文化中，那里的不仅更习惯于戴口罩，并且在问候他人方面有不同的文化习俗，而且他们可能更容易接受关于集体的、促进大家共同利益以及做出个人牺牲的信息。而在美国，例如，你可以看到抗议隔离的示威活动，当然，这是极少数美国人发起的抗议，但其构架方式以及这里总统的支持都是通过个人自由的信息来传达的，也就是个人主义。所以你可以看出在疫情期间，这成了一个问题，对吧？
Because your individual freedoms might put me at risk of dying, especially if I'm immune compromised or elderly. And so that is definitely a big cultural difference that's been studied. The other one that you mentioned is tightness versus looseness. And this is essentially around the issue of social norms. Some communities are very tight in that they regulate and control other people's behavior. Other cultures are very loose, and it's kind of very much like anything goes. And I'll definitely put New York towards the looseness end of the scale, you know, where you can go to the park and you can see all kinds of people doing all kinds of crazy
因为你的个人自由可能会让我面临死亡的风险，尤其是如果我是免疫力低下或老年人的话。所以这绝对是一个已被深入研究的巨大文化差异。你提到的另一个差异是紧密性与宽松性。这本质上是围绕社会规范的问题。有些社区非常紧密，他们规范和控制其他人的行为。另一些文化则非常宽松，有点像百无禁忌。我绝对会把纽约放在刻度盘偏向宽松的那一端，你知道，你走到公园里，可以看到各种各样的人在做各种疯狂的
stuff. And that's just kind of, you feel like that's part of it, part of the vibe here. So what she finds, and she's been studying coronavirus and how it's been spreading, and originally in our paper, we actually had brand new data on COVID from a number of preprints, and she had been doing some work here. We ended up taking those out of the paper because it wasn't, hadn't gone through peer review. We thought that was just a more conservative, cautious way of doing it. But she's already collecting data around the world and finding that there might be some sweet spot where you do need a little bit of tightness in the culture to get people to follow social norms rigidly enough that it reduces the spread of coronavirus. And so it does seem like that tightness might be useful in terms of adherence to,
事情。这就像是其中一部分，是这里氛围的一部分。所以她发现（她一直在研究冠状病毒及其传播方式，最初在我们的论文中，我们实际上掌握了来自许多预印本的关于新冠病毒的全新数据，她也一直在做一些相关研究）。我们最终把这些数据从论文中删除了，因为它们还没有通过同行评审。我们认为这是一种更保守、更谨慎的做法。但她已经在世界各地收集数据，并发现可能存在某种最佳平衡点，即你需要文化中有一点紧密性，让人类足够严格地遵循社会规范，从而减少冠状病毒的传播。因此，这种紧密性似乎在对公共卫生新规范的遵守方面非常有用。
new norms around public health. In addition to your scholarly publishing, you write for mainstream news outlets. And in March, the Washington Post published an op-ed you wrote that talked about partisan polarization during the pandemic. In the piece you cited polling data that shows stark differences in thinking and behavior related to COVID-19, depending on political party, can you describe what you found and how, as you stated, partisan polarization could kill people? Okay, so I will say this. The United States is very polarized right now compared to where it's been historically on numerous types of measures. And basically, that manifests in all kinds of ways, like debating the crowd size at Trump's inauguration versus Barack Obama's.
除了学术出版物，你还为主流新闻媒体撰稿。今年3月，《华盛顿邮报》发表了你写的一篇专栏文章，探讨了疫情期间的党派极化现象。你在文章中引用了民调数据，显示出与新冠肺炎相关的思考和行为存在明显差异，这取决于政党归属。你能描述一下你的发现以及你所说的“党派极化可能会杀人”是什么意思吗？好的，那我这样说吧。与历史上的情况相比，美国目前在许多类型的指标上都极度极化。基本上，这表现在各种各样的事情上，比如争论特朗普就职典礼与巴拉克·奥巴马就职典礼的人群规模。
And in some cases, those are pretty trivial discussions. In the context of a pandemic, it's potentially extremely dangerous. If some people are taking the coronavirus seriously and others are not because they're tuned into different media kind of ecosystems or listening to different leaders with different messages and beliefs, it could be deadly. And so what's happening in the United States are a couple things. The first thing is there's been a pretty continuous partisan gap between Republicans and Democrats in how seriously they take the coronavirus. In particular, Democrats have taken it way more seriously for months, pretty much in the the beginning, Republicans less so. In fact, you know, Trump was famously quoted saying that
在某些情况下，这些都是相当微不足道的讨论。但在疫情的背景下，这可能极其危险。如果一些人认真对待冠状病毒，而另一些人则不然，因为他们收听不同的媒体生态系统，或者听取带有不同信息和信念的不同领导人的言论，这可能是致命的。因此，美国正在发生几件事。首先，在如何认真对待冠状病毒这个问题上，共和党人和民主党人之间一直存在着相当持续的党派差距。特别是，几个月来，民主党人一直认真对待得多，从一开始基本上就是这样，而共和党人则不然。事实上，你知道，特朗普曾有一句名言说
the Democrat and media's concern about coronavirus was, I think he called it a Democratic hoax. And so he thought they were overblowing it. And Fox News was covering it in this way in right-wing talk radio. And so you just saw this in poll after poll after poll. What you've seen now is that that partisan gap has closed a little bit in polls. And in fact, I saw one poll, probably from about two weeks ago saying that over 80% of Republicans now supported and were engaging in the public health practices around coronavirus. It was still higher among Democrats. I think it was 92 or 94% of Democrats. So what you now see is, in some sense, you still see the partisan gap, but you also see in many ways an extremely rare bipartisan consensus around
民主党人和媒体对冠状病毒的担忧，我想他称之为“民主党的骗局”。所以他认为他们是在夸大其词。福克斯新闻网和右翼谈话广播也是这样报道的。所以你会在一个又一个的民调中看到这一点。你现在看到的是，民调中的党派差距已经缩小了一点。事实上，我看到过一个民调，大概是两周前发布的，称超过80%的共和党人现在支持并参与了围绕冠状病毒的公共卫生实践。民主党人的比例仍然更高，我想92%或94%的民主党人都支持。所以你现在看到的是，在某种程度上，你仍然能看到党派差距，但你在许多方面也看到了关于这个问题的极其罕见的跨党派共识。
this issue as well. So you see both those things. Both those normally are contradictory. You don't normally see bipartisan consensus and a stubborn partisan gap, but you do see it now. And so we, many political scientists have been studying this. I am working on a paper with this. It's under review right now, led by Anton Golwitzer and some other students and postdocs at Yale. And what we are looking at is tracking people's cell phone movements, because sometimes when people report something in a poll with a pollster, you don't know if they're just like signaling that they're loyal to the president. but they actually don't believe what they're saying or what he's saying. So we looked at movement based on anonymized smartphone movements for every single county in the United States.
所以你同时看到了这两种现象。这两种现象通常是相互矛盾的。你通常不会看到跨党派共识和一个顽固的党派差距同时存在，但你现在确实看到了。因此，我们许多政治学家一直在研究这一点。我正在写一篇关于这方面的论文，目前正在接受评审，由安东·戈尔维策（Anton Golwitzer）以及耶鲁大学的一些其他学生和博士后带头。我们正在研究的是追踪人们手机的移动轨迹，因为有时当人们在民调中向民调人员汇报某事时，你不知道他们是否只是在表态效忠总统，但实际上并不相信他们自己或他说的话。因此，我们查看了美国每一个县基于匿名智能手机移动数据的行为。
And what we found is there is a partisan gap there in terms of social movement. And so in Democratic counties and Democratic states, you've seen greater physical distancing and reduced movement than you do in Republican states and counties. And so that's, again, that difference has been pretty stubborn. Even though both people from both counties and both states have been moving less and less over time, you still see that there's a partisan gap. And now we're trying to see if that predicts infections and deaths, mortality, which you would predict it will, just because if you're exposed to more people moving around, you just put yourself more at risk. So we are essentially analyzing it with real behavior at the level of counties and states.
我们发现在社会流动性方面确实存在党派差距。因此，在民主党执政的县和州，你看到的物理距离拉开幅度和移动减少程度，要比在共和党执政的州和县更大。所以，这种差异再次表现得相当顽固。尽管来自两党各县和各州的人们随着时间的推移都在不断减少出行，但你仍然能看到党派差距的存在。现在我们正试图看看这是否能预测感染率和死亡率，你完全可以预测它是可以的，因为如果你接触到更多四处走动的人，你就会让自己面临更大的风险。因此，我们基本上是在县和州的层面上，用真实的行为来分析它，
to see if it manifests in the kind of outcomes that you might expect. But basically, it suggests that polarization is not just something that you see debated online or on different partisan media. It's something that might matter and have life and death consequences for people in a pandemic. So it's a very serious, dangerous issue. Now, you've also looked at brain differences between liberals and conservatives, something that sounds almost like sci-fi, but apparently it actually exists. And I'm just wondering, do these physiological differences mean that based on our brain structures,
看看它是否会表现出你所预期的结果。但基本上，这表明极化不仅是你看到在网上或不同党派媒体上争论的事情。它是可能在疫情中对人们产生影响并具有生死攸关后果的事情。所以这是一个非常严肃、危险的问题。现在，你还研究了自由派和保守派之间的大脑差异，这听起来几乎像是科幻小说，但显然它确实存在。我只是想知道，这些生理上的差异是否意味着，基于我们的大脑结构，决定我们政治偏见的是先天（nature）而非后天（nurture）？
that it's nature and not nurture necessarily that determines our political biases? Yeah. So we have basically looked at brain structure differences between liberals and conservatives. And this was partly inspired by a couple findings. One was genetic work with identical and non-identical twins. And they found that basically using classic genetic studies, you could, determine that something like 40 to 50% of people's political partisan preferences, their political ideology is biologically based. So we often think of, you know, debates between presidential
是的。我们基本上研究了自由派和保守派之间的大脑结构差异。这部分是受到几个发现的启发。其中之一是对同卵双胞胎和异卵双胞胎的基因研究。他们发现，通过使用经典的基因研究，你可以确定人们大约40%到50%的政治党派偏好和政治意识形态是有生物学基础的。所以我们经常会想到总统之间的辩论
candidates and, you know, learning about new ideas as being the core way that we develop our political preferences. But it turns out, it seems like a lot of it is just genetic. So if you agree with your parents' politics, it might not be because they talked about it at the dinner table. It might be because you just share their orientation towards the world. And then there was some research coming out of England. One of the authors on it was Colin Firth, the Academy Award-winning actor. The year that he won the Academy Award, he also collaborated with some neuroscientists to see if there's brain structure differences between liberals and conservatives. And in fact, they found in two studies, pretty large studies, that there was. So conservatives have larger gray matter
候选人，你知道，了解新思想是我们形成政治偏好的核心方式。但事实证明，似乎很大程度上这只是遗传。所以如果你同意你父母的政治观点，可能不是因为他们在饭桌上谈论过它。可能是因为你们对世界的取向是一样的。后来英国出了一些研究。其中一位作者是奥斯卡获奖演员科林·费斯。在他获得奥斯卡奖的那一年，他还与一些神经科学家合作，看看自由派和保守派的大脑结构是否存在差异。事实上，他们在两项相当大的研究中发现确实存在。所以保守派拥有更大的灰质
volume density in their amygdala, and liberals have it in their anterior cingulate cortex. And we tried to replicate that finding in the United States in a couple's studies. And we found it was there, but it was pretty weak. What we found was a bigger, more robust difference was just people's attitudes towards the system that they were in. So people who support and justify the existing political and social systems and institutions tend to have larger gray matter volume density in their amygdala. And that normally correlates pretty highly with conservatism, but it's not exactly the same thing. So basically, we found kind of a somewhat consistent evidence, but not completely. The findings were a little more nuanced once you got out of
杏仁核的体积密度，而自由派则在前扣带皮层中拥有它。我们在美国的一些研究中试图复制这一发现。我们发现它是存在的，但相当微弱。我们发现更大、更稳健的差异只是人们对自己所处系统态度的差异。因此，支持和正视现有政治、社会系统及机构的人，其杏仁核的灰质体积密度往往更大。这通常与保守主义有很高的相关性，但并不完全是一回事。所以基本上，我们发现了一些相对一致的证据，但并不完全一致。一旦离开
Britain and came to the United States. Pretty amazing. So are you at all optimistic that the coronavirus is going to shrink our partisan divide? Is that going to be one of the outcomes of all this? Yeah, so my prediction when I wrote that article for the Washington Post was as it gets closer to you and it starts to affect you or your family members or your community and they start to get sick or die, you kind of, you know, the rose, the group colored glasses that you have on, your partisan lens that you see the world might start to break down and you get grounded in reality a little bit more of the real risks to you. And we have seen a little bit of that. Like I said, with polling, what you've seen is pretty widespread bipartisan consensus around the country. So I think it's kind of an open book how that changes as a function of if you get sick or a friend get sick. We don't have the data on that yet. But I think that it certainly part by part of our partisanship is getting reduced. But again, you know, when you have political leaders who are running for an election and, you know, they think they can benefit.
英国来到美国，这些发现就变得更加细致了。真了不起。那么，你是否对冠状病毒会缩小我们的党派分歧抱有任何乐观态度呢？这会是这一切的结果之一吗？是的，所以我为《华盛顿邮报》撰写那篇文章时的预测是，当它离你越来越近，开始影响你、你的家人或你的社区，他们开始生病或死亡时，你知道的，你戴着的玫瑰色、群体的有色眼镜，你看世界的党派视角可能会开始崩溃，你会对你面临的真实风险有更多的现实感。我们也确实看到了一些这样的情况。就像我说的，通过民意调查，你看到的是全国范围内相当广泛的两党共识。所以我认为这取决于你或你的朋友生病时情况会如何变化，这还是一个未知数。我们还没有这方面的数据。但我认为这确实在一定程度上减少了我们的党派偏见。但话说回来，你知道，当政治领袖在竞选时，你知道，他们认为自己可以从中受益。
from division, that it's going to be hard to imagine a way that you reduce those partisan differences completely. In fact, in some ways, some measures have seen them start to increase in the last few days last week or two. So it's kind of a fluid, it's a fluid situation. I would like to be optimistic that people all kind of rally around this issue. But there's lots of people who are working against that in all kinds of ways. So, you know, I hope that people do what's healthy and safe. But You know, I'm a scientist. I'm not the average person speaking on this. Well, this has been really interesting. I appreciate you're taking the time to talk to us today, Dr. Van Babel. Thank you. Thanks so much for having me. I look forward to hearing the discussion on your podcast.
由于分裂，很难想象有什么方法可以完全减少这些党派分歧。事实上，在某些方面，一些衡量标准显示它们在过去几天或一两周内开始增加。所以这是一个不断变化、流动的情况。我希望乐观地认为人们都会团结在这个问题周围。但有很多人在以各种方式破坏这一点。所以，你知道，我希望人们做出健康和安全的行为。但是你知道，我是一位科学家。我不是就此发言的普通人。好吧，这真的很有趣。范·巴贝尔博士，感谢您今天抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢。非常感谢邀请我。我期待着听到你们播客上的讨论。
Me too. The American Psychological Association has many resources and tipsheets available on our website for help in navigating the pandemic. Visit us at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website, at speakingof psychology.org. And you can subscribe to our podcast on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and please be sure to leave us a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org,
我也是。美国心理协会在我们的网站上提供了许多资源和提示单，以帮助应对这场大流行。请访问我们的网址 APA.org。您也可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到“心理学之声”先前的剧集。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方订阅我们的播客，请务必给我们留下评分。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org，
at speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即 speaking of psychology（全部为一个词），@APA.org。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理协会。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。